hello everyone I hope everybody's doing
fine today not going on out there
I kind of stir the Beehive you know and
all the bees come out you know and they
start attacking me like the bear who
wants that honey and no matter what and
I get a lot of that anyways what I've
been doing this week we've been doing a
little bit about working a little bit on
what is irrationality and the context of
that is mathematical physics is
mathematical physics rational
objectively rational and so we try to
establish some criteria to see if we can
qualify the theories right we're
referring to the theories here right
we're referring to is mathematical
physics rational and mathematical
physics has primarily two branches one
is quantum mechanics the other one is
general relativity it's got a third
branch which is not having too much
success in that string theory you're
trying to end the string theorists
mathematically are trying to unite
general relativity with quantum
mechanics and the issue there the the
central point of string theory is
gravity because right now there's no way
of uniting gravity from quantum
mechanics the equations always right
with general relativity and general
relativity is considered to be proved
it's already a fact you know all the
mathematicians voted for it so it's a
fact now but quantum you know it's got
to have that graviton it's not there
they can't find it
and I guess they never will you know you
can't explain gravity with rabbit
tongues with discrete particles and so
this takes us down first to you know
what is irrational and I've established
some criteria I think we need to define
these words to use them in some way
Adrian was suggesting the other day you
know we don't have to use the word
irrational because that's kind of
offensive or people have different ideas
about what is rational what is
irrational and so on and so he says use
the word a that we're dog two or three
well it is to some degree like okay but
it's it's offensive in this sense that
if you label someone's theory as
irrational first you'll think it's just
your opinion and second he'll say oh so
you're saying that I'm irrational well
no you're not irrational unless you
believe in it but again that's attacking
the person you're really attacking this
theory you're trying to put some
criteria where you can objectively say
that it's not rational by this I mean
it's not a part of science that's that's
the main point if in order for it to be
within science it's got to be rational
that's why the definition of science is
rational explanation so that's where the
word rational fits in and then the
question is whether we have objective
criteria for that or just opinions like
you know well you put that criterion in
there because it favors your your theory
and nothing else at favors your your
position and I don't think that's what
we're doing here I am almost convinced
you know if you look at the criteria
here here's a list of it converting a
concept into physical tuned to a
physical object the first one you know
it sounds like to me that's that's
straightforward I don't think anybody
can challenge that if you use a concept
and you start moving it around you say
love move mountains you got a problem
and then there are other criteria there
using key undefined words but you make
your theory you know the ones that make
or break your theory you don't define
them or you don't use them consistently
and the theory doesn't follow from the
assumptions and also when people claim
to describe when they're actually
explaining and
I'm sorry when people claim to explain
when they actually describe and I wrote
an article about that yes today this
morning so these are the criteria I'm
offering for what is something that is
rational and you know way in this case
irrational or yeah you can twist that
around say let if you meet any of those
conditions you are irrational if you
don't meet those conditions then you
have a rational theory and obviously you
know you're welcome to add and subtract
as long as you can justify the additions
and subtractions why is quantum
mechanics irrational I am i labeling it
as irrational mathematical physics first
now the branches quantum mechanics why
is quantum mechanics irrational well the
the bread and butter of quantum
mechanics is the particle you know you
can't live without a particle in quantum
mechanics because that's what quantum
means quantum is a packet of energy or
supposedly and that's what they call you
know a particle whatever that means to
you some people visualize it as some
kind of little dot that's moving other
people have other opinions about it or
other notions of it and they say look
you know we're not referring to a
corpuscle what we're referring to is
something totally different and so
that's when you start and these are the
mathematicians that take that position
you say well then what are you referring
to if you're not to a corpuscle and here
is what a particle is a particle is an
excited state of a field there you have
it folks
particle is an excited state of a field
you have a field and it's the excited
state of that field or a portion of it
that they call particle they refer to
that region right out of the field as a
particle what this means in that
particular system maybe in a vacuum
state zero particles or in various
excited states of the field one or more
particles so you either have zero
particles where you have a vacuum state
and I don't know what they mean by that
because they never
now is that there is a total vacuum they
never define what they mean by vacuum
they say space is made of particles so I
don't know what vacuum is made out of
they claim to bring virtual particles
from the vacuum so I don't understand
what vacuum means in in quantum they
have all these different definitions for
vacuum but let's go with the field the
field is a mathematical entity a
mathematical entity whatever that is
that exists throughout space and time in
other words a field of one particle
extends all the way to infinity to
wherever the edges of space-time is one
particle it sounds like they're
describing the rope you know be an
interconnect interconnecting all the
atoms in the universe that's what it
sounds like they're saying there there's
something called a field and there's a
potential at each point in space around
a particle and that potential extends to
different degrees all the way to the
edge of the universe it's like in fact
they give you an example there they said
the temperature in the room in principle
you can define a function that gives the
temperature at any point X in the room
at any time T fields are defined
similarly in other words you have you
have temperature in the room right and
you have the heater in the center of the
room well as you work your way outwards
radially from the heater it gets colder
and colder and colder all the way to the
walls at least right so what happens you
take a measurement with your thermometer
and as you get closer to the heater the
temperature the the thermometer raises
you know reads higher readings and as
you get farther away gets lower readings
that's what they call a field it's the
environment around a central point and
you can choose what your central point
is or what the radius of that central
point is you know you can just
arbitrarily say well I'm going to choose
only one meter or two meters or three
meters or whatever and then it says
that's the classical field by the way
now quantum field is what you get when
you quantize a classical field that
means you turn a region right
you you you cut you cut a chunk of that
classical field that extends all the way
to the wall you you describe you you cut
up maybe a sphere somewhere in the
center of the room right and that's a
quantized field and that's gonna be the
the famous particle of quantum in this
process the field becomes a function
that gives an operator at each point in
space-time instead of a numerical value
and you're saying what are these guys
talking about and here here I've
Illustrated the field for you this is a
field according to quantum ok and what
you have is a it's a mathematical
concept not a physical object that's
what the particle is going to be it's
going to be a portion of that field and
a field is is not very exciting unless
something happens and what it has to do
it's got to vibrate and the only way
it's kind of vibrant is if you add
energy so you have energy on your right
side there now that I my energy is green
maybe yours is yellow I don't know and
you infuse energy into the field it
starts moving all those bedsprings and
it starts vibrating and that feeling
again this is just a two-dimensional
field here what we're talking about is
something that extends throughout all of
space radially filled space completely
and all this is vibrating out there and
that's what they call a field and that's
the quantum field the quantum field is
simply a portion of that and that's what
they'll call the quantum so again we're
talking about concepts in within
concepts within concepts that's all
they're doing these are mathematical
concepts and nothing else and here you
have a definition of a field more
clearly a field is an imaginary concept
or you could say a mathematical concept
postulated because we have no better
explanation that's the that's the answer
that you get for the word field in the
old days when something like magnetism
had an effect that didn't involve matter
touching something but was able to
affect matter over limited range it was
called a field in the 19th century with
that light were radio waves
you know we're vibrations or excitations
in the electromagnetic field in the
early 20th century it was discovered
that matter was really tiny bits of
stuff held together by fields mostly
electromagnetic field but within the
nucleus to other kinds of fields and
then as quantum theory developed in
which particles did not have always
particular locations or States it was
difficult to continue calling the little
bits of stuff particles so what happened
finally quantum field theory postulated
that everything is a field great there
is an electron field for example a
particular electron is a packet of
vibrations in that field some physics
today a field is an imaginary
space-filling idea that vibrates if you
add energy to it that's what these
people have concluded after 2000 years
of brainstorming what do you think of
that essentially looking at the
invisible right looking at the the
unseen yeah and they're just saying ok
since we can't figure out we can't see
what it is we can't empirically deduce
right what is here yeah we're gonna
dispense with the empiricism on on the
shape level we're not gonna care what it
looks like or what it is or what it does
we don't care what it does that's all we
care about I just care but we don't care
about what it looks like or what's what
the unseen would look like if it were
seen there just saying okay this magnet
or this gravity let's say this planet
alright this behind it is pulling on
this moon with some unseen force that
we'll never be able to see so forget
what it looks like we're just gonna look
at its effect and we're just gonna keep
it invisible we're just gonna say okay
anything that's invisible or basically
gonna call the field anything that's
invisible that
upon other objects we're gonna call fuel
I mean for that matter they might as
well call gusts of air fields yeah if
someone blows on on a pencil of mows it
first let me start here do we have image
I can't seem to get an image here on my
computer
are you okay can you see me there okay I
don't know why I don't have an image
here okay sorry about that yeah and so
what they're basically replacing any so
so we have these invisible phenomenon
right we have gravity for example we
have magnetism for example and I'm just
gonna throw in air into that one because
it's also invisible although it's more
visible than the others but they're
essentially taking anything that we
can't see
empirically no one can see it we'll
never be able to see it because it's lit
it's just invisible by all means but its
effects are observable that's all that
we're talking about the magic we're just
talking about the effects so gravity has
an effective magnetism obviously as an
effect but we're just looking at the
effects and not what the what is causing
the effects that's why they use the word
field because fields is basically a
catch-all word for it is the range of a
face of a phenomenon but you know they
use that also when they use the word
energy when to use the word mass when
you use the word force they're talking
about all these weird you know I don't
know concepts which they introduced in
there and and this is where the issue
comes in that these people are just
playing around with with concept they're
moving concepts around I mean you would
think that the word particle needs no
you know no sophisticated explanation or
definition or any you know you don't
need to go through all these tangents
and and
and clauses and redefinitions there's no
I mean a particles the particle is a
particle right no apparently in quantum
they had to convert the particle into a
field they had to describe it with a
wave function saying well the particle
is not always a particle sometimes it's
a wave or it forms part of a wave it's a
it's it's an ingredient of the pick wave
and what they mean by that is we don't
really know where it's at
and so it's got this general wave
picture and it's somewhere in there with
our equation we can tell you where it's
at so they get into a lot of stuff that
has nothing to do with anything we just
want to know what a particle looks like
that's what we want to know could we
call a gust of air a field yeah that's
essentially what it is yeah gust of air
is a vibration in what we call if if
here is a field and we won't say that it
extends all the way to the edge of the
universe we'll just say here is what
covers the earth right like a shell and
it gets thinner less oxygen I guess as
you go further out until there's none of
it right let's call that that halo that
covers the earth we'll call it a field
the field of air so you can take the
gust of air or a wind or whatever just a
chunk of it and say this is a particle
I'm gonna call it a particle you say
what do you mean a particle yeah this
this little lump of oxygen that is
moving that is vibrating I'll call that
a field I'll call that a particle I'm
sorry and you say well yeah but then
would it what are you really talking
about are you saying that you're gonna
collide this against something else we
colliding you know bunches of air
against another bunch of air and when
you look at the so called field you know
a bunch of it I mean in case of air you
can still talk about two lumps of air
colliding we can all imagine that but
that's not what these people are talking
about these people are not saying those
particles that can constitute the air
those are just values so this lump this
quantum ball this chunk that you took
from the field and what you call
particle
is not made of like atoms or even
particles they I mean here you have a
particle made of particles essentially
right but when you look in there each
one is just a value it's just about some
mathematical value that's all it is
but until that's why the way it gets so
weird you have to understand this
concept but if they're gonna use field
for all every visible object absently or
invisible areas of effect let's call it
that areas of effect why why can't you
extrapolate that I can't you why can't I
be the field for example you're a field
according to them you are a field you're
humans formed a big field and you're
just one lump eight billion billion
forms of field and you're just one
little vibrating chunk of the field but
now you're saying you're the field okay
and what about it yeah is it field
essentially what they're doing is
they're basically cookie cutter in
cutting out you know like a Photoshop
you you copy paste you can cut paste
yeah basically cut out a shape and say
okay everything in this shape I'm ready
called the X field okay kind of what
they're doing in the end you can do that
to anything I can call this bottle the
bottle field yeah everything that's
within that this bottle is is I may call
the field but I'm not looking at the
bottle I'm looking at the effect or the
room that the bottle takes up it's it's
it's it's like I'm taking out the
property of volume out of the bottle or
in these cases of invisible things we're
taking out the property of magnetism
phrase we're looking at the properties
of that reach out of the area without
actually looking at what causes the
effect oh we all we care about is the
effect and that's what that that's the
first issue the other issue we we
absolutely have to understand that the
field is not comprised of of anything
solid it's not comprised of objects the
field that the quantum mathematicians
are talking about
is comprised of values of mathematical
quantities that's what it is but again
because we only care about the numbers
how much they look at the properties
they look at what properties are
included in that region that's all that
something we can measure you know what
is the size what is the energy how fast
is it moving those kinds of things those
are the things that the mathematicians
are interested in they call that physics
the study of physics but what are they
studying their studying abstract
concepts as mr. Bourne said you know
physics has become more and more
abstract he said in 1920s today it's
entirely abstract there's nothing
physical about it so it's got nothing to
do with physics because physics is
physical abstract has to do with
abstraction there's the exact opposite
of physical and so you know these people
are doing abstractions and what's the
abstraction the main the the the you can
say the bread and butter the brick that
quantum uses today is the field that's
what they deal with from the lowest
level upwards that you just talked about
fields because field is is just
shorthand or a synonym for area of
effect correct and that's all we care
about the effects so forget anything
else we just care about the area the
area of affect the field we have a
particle as this area of effect so
anything within this area or they called
the particles effect field and there's
two things you should conclude from that
notion the first one is that mathematics
is deemed to be the language of physics
it's deemed to be the language of
science the language of the universe
I've heard on the one hand and on the
other that experiment is you know doing
experiments and verifying and
corroborating verifying what the other
guy did doing experiments is part of not
only a scientific method but an integral
part of physics
and the question is whether any of those
to belong to physics or to science at
all and I know people are gonna roll
dirt into this people are gonna roll
their eyes and say hold it what do you
mean experiments are not part of physics
what do you mean that mathematics is not
the language of physics and what you
have to keep in mind here is that
physics today what they call physics
actually mathematical physics has
evolved in that direction simply because
mathematics is what these people do so
they said look very simple we're gonna
equate science with math and we're going
to equate physics with math because
that's what we do and what are they
doing they're doing calculations during
the doing equations that's on one hand
the other they're doing experiments the
other branch you know the people who do
who go to the lab that people who do go
to the accelerator the in fact the
people at NASA who send rockets into the
air to do the the cosmic stuff versus
the other guys who do the atomic stuff
right and so that's what they do these
guys do experiments and these guys do
equations and so mathematical physics
has evolved as in synonym of science and
of physics and you might say so what's
the problem
well the problem is that they ended up
with all these irrational explanations
and they dismiss them saying well we
don't care about the explanations we
don't care about the physical
interpretation because that's not
physics what physics is is the equations
and the fact that you did an experiment
and was able to measure and bring me a
measurement that I can use in the
equation so that's what the whole thing
has evolved to and I'm saying that we
have to stop this we have to rethink
what is the purpose not only of science
but of physics and when you when you
look at then you say look if physics is
about rational explanations these guys
are completely off the mark these guys
aren't not doing physics or science and
you know again the language of physics
as far as I'm concerned is not math and
we don't have to do experiments
experiments we have to explain not
to them you can do all the experiments
you want yeah I can drop the pen a
million times that doesn't mean I'm
gonna understand why that pen falls to
the floor I got to come with an
explanation for that phenomenon or for
three magnets that attract each other
that's one part the other part is we do
them with objects the language of
physics is not mathematics the language
of physics is illustration I should be
able to show you a movie of my mechanism
and you should look at watch the movie
and pretty much understand what I'm
talking about yes they do physics you
racist I can explain it to him no in his
era a blind man would probably wouldn't
be able to do equations either for that
matter or do experiments at the lab he
probably would be able to find the lab
without his dog you know but my point
here is that the language of physics nah
I won't say science because I divide
also science into philosophy and physics
but the language of physics is
illustration you should be able to do
physics I mean you can't do physics
without an object what is an object that
which has shape very simple and so if
you're gonna do physics you better have
an object that means you should be able
to put a shape some kind of shape on the
on each one of the frames of your film
and show me the movie of what your
mechanism that your proposed mechanism
is that's the theory and to say well
know what we do is describe and here's
the equation well what did you do you
know let's let's replace the variables
in equation with a number Papa Papa I
replace the 10 variables and the
constant if necessary in your equation
with some numbers fine I get one result
one point that's that's all I get so I
plot that point I'll plot it on a chart
now I replace all the variables with
another number and then with another
number and with an unknown number and I
keep plotting all these points and I get
a trend well that's that's what math
does it what is it what have I done I've
all I did was characterize motion I have
been what I've done is just watch how
something is behaving or moving or
whatever that's all I've done and that's
a description that's all there any
question can do and the question is
whether Fizz
you know it's just describing you you go
to the to the show you watch the you
know the magician and he cuts the lady
in half so so what did he do
are you just gonna say well he cut her
into pieces had twenty strokes of the
saw he did in 15 seconds
that's all description you haven't
explained it yeah what I want to know is
how you did the trick
that's what I want to know that's where
you have to burn you know some gray
matter but to say that you know the guy
cut her in 15 seconds with 20 strokes of
the saw that's a description is that
science and that's where we have a
difference I would say they're only
doing half science Oh half I would pull
what they're doing is the necessary part
but not the integral part the whole
point of science is to expects to
explain things but you kind of need it
starting but you kind of need to know
what it is you're going to explain and
it's nice to have the guy drop the pen
it's nice to have them you know exactly
you know describe every single inch of
what you are to explain so you kind of
need you know the paleontologist needs
to find a bone before you can explain
where it came from that kind of thing
okay I would still put that insight in
science and physics but it's kind of
like the the grunt work part it's kind
of like the the yeah okay we have to do
that obviously at some point it's like
the someone has to put the tools up on
for the magician magician can't can't do
the trick without any island without any
any of it well yeah you can't explain if
you haven't seen what he's gonna do work
with but that's not the that's kind of
like the first half way okay that's
great we're doing a lot of prep work for
for the science but we're not doing the
actual science part you know the the
juice of the line you just have a whole
bunch of lemon Ryan's and we don't have
the juice of the lemon and that's why I
separate that I'm saying you know what
he just this referred to is the
description part and we include that if
you want to call it a description we
include that under what we call the
assumptions or hypothesis what is the
hypothesis includes first the objects
that you're going to use second the
definition you've got to have those
straight the key definitions and then
the the what he was referring to is you
know the initial scene or what you're
going to be explaining so you have to
have some event you describe the event
you say look the magician cut the lady
in half okay and that's just a very
quick summary right and that's part of
the hypothesis that's part of the
assumption because you explained you to
someone who didn't see the magician cut
the lady in half so you say look let me
tell you what I'm going to explain I'm
going to explain that there was this man
on the stage and he cut the lady in half
you know so many strokes so many seconds
he cut her to pieces she came back in
one great that's what happened so that's
what you're going to explain and now the
guy says okay explain it what how did it
happen
what was the mechanism and that's where
science vibrates because now you got to
burn some grey matter you got to burn
some you know some neurons in there to
try to figure out how did he do that how
did he do that tree that's where our
science vibrates to say that he cut her
in half
well that doesn't take it you know I
measured there were two pieces now
there's only one I mean what is that
science that's the question I equated
more to the detective analogy he's a
detective gets to a crime scene he
starts to pick up the clues and and look
around and kind of kind of gather
information
you know describe it the the scene
perfectly or is it at least the the
crucial parts or what he deems crucial
let's put it that way okay but
physicists nowadays are stuck on that
part they're stuck on the gathering
information okay collected from a master
debater yeah we have the detective there
are two years at the crime scene still
still picking up clues they don't have
and they don't have an explanation for
how the murder happen can we explain the
murder
the burner has already already got away
let's get to it buddy you know that's a
good analogy very good analogy I love
myself because of that he comes up with
all these analogy and that's a good
analogy imagine a detective here we have
Sherlock Holmes and his buddy you know
and they go to the crime scene and they
spend the rest of their lives just
describing that there was blood here and
and and you know in the the victim fell
from the stairs and she had a knife
stuck yeah the question is hold on and
and we're not done because we have to
measure their thighs their toe we have
to measure everything with the length of
the night and they're also doing tests
they're dropping people from stairs to
see if they make the same shape when
they'll end up on the floor and in that
time let's do it again
oh we noticed when people go see if it's
repeatable so you do it too you know you
go to another you know Australia you do
that to see if she if you drop from the
stairs you end up in the same way you
know so they do all this stuff right
that's true and and they do a lot of
measurements a lot of numbers a lot of
equations and they never tell you they
can never tell the judge or the jury
look this is what we think happened they
can't tell you or they'll say and try
but they come up with these like
patchwork Lihue irrational like yangshin
yes let's just give them something just
that's a good analogy or didn't care
about the explanation part yeah I'll
tell you like you said they confuse
explanations with description but you
know how they explained it to the jury
let me tell you how they explain to jury
says well the victim died in in this
universe in a parallel universe she
continued to live and in another one she
won the lottery and so on you know so
they have all these you know they have
the multiple multi universe theory where
you know every event breaks up into you
know these gazillions of universes and
in this universe she died you know and
she was killed so they don't have to
explain it because you know it's just
that's how the wavefunction collapsed
here in another universe the
wavefunction maybe doesn't collapse or
who knows or
lapses into something else into a eunuch
or leprechaun for all we know this is
the issue the issue that these people
never explained to the jury what what
they think happened how they think it
happened they just do measurements in
the equations and spit out facts and
it's all we proven it yeah what did you
prove I proved the fact I proved what
happened not how it happened that's the
issue
I like the pen dropping experiment many
times you just have to do once it's
amazing when you do that experiment
because the pen goes like it moves on
its own when you let go of it you go
straight down it doesn't stay there you
would think it should stay there and it
doesn't for some reason and magically it
always goes that it never even goes up
that's not my point my point is uh-huh
everyone always says well you have to do
experiments to find out to find out
empirically Aaron's always taught me on
experiments and proof right but the pen
dropping one cuts through all of it look
anyone can do that experiment I mean you
could call it a straw man and how do you
make us it's not a real experiment or
whatever but it's good it's it is there
anyway you have to explain how that
happened I describe how fast the Pens
falling now I describe the shape of the
planet not describe angels not I mean
unless that's maybe well maybe that's my
theory is you're gonna use to explain
but explain like get to the point
already yeah yeah no matter who does
that they have to explain that
phenomenon and that's totally true you
know you gotta get at some point you're
gonna have an explanation for that
I mean if I just keep dropping pens and
say I repeated the experiment I verified
his prediction it does fall at 9.8
meters per second squared
acceleration etc etc etc you know what
have you done you yeah here's the
equation Newton's equation mass times
rands divided by distance Square all
that is just the description you have
not explained a phenomenon and okay so
that's a regarding quantum okay
but it doesn't stop there we also have
the
problem where you know we have it also
in general relativity which deals with
something else which deals with our
cosmic world and specifically it deals
with space-time and here you have you
know the question is whether you can and
again they're dealing with concepts here
you add space with time and you end up
with some kind of four-dimensional
object unimaginable as they tell you
because they'll come see that it's
unimaginable and I'm saying can you add
a 3d Rock right here's a rock it's Reda
mention or hopefully right I hope you
can see that yeah that it's a
three-dimensional Rock and add time any
way you want you can you can argue that
it happened the two o'clock in the
afternoon that's an event you know
that's when you saw the rock or when you
picked up the rock or whatever or you
can say the rock flew for three seconds
you know just take it any way you want
do you end up with a four dimensional
object because you unite three a 3d rock
with a with time and you know what they
do is they end up in mathematical
physics they end up with this object
they say if you add space 3d space by
which they mean a volume some kind of
object right and you add it to time
whether it's a two o'clock in the
afternoon or just the three seconds that
went by you end up with this with some
kind of four-dimensional object which in
this case as you can see it's a
two-dimensional object that shows that
apparently depicts a three-dimensional
object so it's a projection of a
three-dimensional object in two
dimensions but as you can see it's
moving okay that's I guess the the
motion part is the fourth I mentioned is
this a four-dimensional object I mean I
can imagine this one so why do you say
that some you know
unimaginable if it's unimaginable
unimaginable it's because what you are
staring at is not what they're
describing mathematically as a shrimping
if I know you guys are in the trippy
yeah but see the issue you're saying is
basically there's no there's no such
thing as a 3-dimensional that's right
four dimensional picture there's four
dimensional gifts and four dimensional
videos because it always has to has have
time involved right and the question is
whether and again if I take a rock and I
add time to it in any way you want to
o'clock the event happened three seconds
is what happened I don't care you know
just add time any way you want
does that convert the rock into a
unimaginable four dimensional object and
obviously that's nonsense especially
when they follow that up and say oh by
the way we worked the rock we we warped
rock time so not only do we have an
unimaginable object but we warped it we
warp the rock end time we did it with
gravity no does that make sense
sounds cool I don't know and I got a
gravity sucking up here's my fourth
dimension and a black hole comes in and
then such as you another dimension yes
magic yeah good movie doesn't explain
anything but yeah and so this is the
issue the issue is not only quantum
because some people say well quantum we
don't understand but everybody
understands general relativity no that's
nonsense as well if we go by the rules
that I establish here for what is
rationality has sounds douchey okay we
go by my rules by my rules okay if we go
by the definition the criteria that we
have for rationality and we and the
first item on the list is concepts
turned into objects space-time is a
constant you can't say space-time is a
physical object and that's what they say
they say that space-time is an
unimaginable object you say what kind of
object is it what's a mathematic
object what do you mean a mathematical
is it an object or not what do you mean
mathematical mathematical means we can
describe it mathematically with an
equation but we can't show it to you
because it's unimaginable well then are
we are we describing or explaining or
whatever the real world I mean are we
referring to the real world if it's
something that's unimaginable and that's
when they add and they say well you know
our minds are so puny we're just people
mere humans we're not gods
so this is beyond our comprehension no
kid and this is the problem the problem
is that they never get to to explain
anything you know like Mary Poppins
because what happens yeah Mary Poppins
no she it's the banker asks her Mary
Poppins will you please explain this
like what happened here in lane yourself
and she looks at him and says I would I
would make one thing absolutely clear
yes I never explain anything and that's
essentially what the mathematicians they
never explain anything yeah you know you
can get to the end of the onion you know
the center of the Apple you won't find
any seeds there's nothing there you
never get an explanation and and of
course they dismiss that saying well we
don't do explanations because human mind
the human mind cannot comprehend all
this stuff because the common sense of
the universe is not the same as the
common sense of us petty human ants
that's that's their it that's their
answer and that's where it ends you know
the question gets we have Martin
Carville here do they quantum and
general relativity claim to explain the
nature or are they claiming they
illustrate math I mean do they
acknowledge the difference between
explanations and descriptions probably
not no well hold it no let me clarify
that that is an important question
because it goes like this some
mathematicians like you'll get this guy
Donald Simon Act which I always quote
because that's one of the quotes I found
there
he's from the
University in Pennsylvania and he's a
emeritus professor and he says science
doesn't explain science describes it
seems like he establishes a difference
between the description and explanation
and I know there's other people out
there the other one I found out there
and I'm trying to get more of these
evidences out there you know so I hear
it so that we can produce it from the
horse's mouth
the other one is Steven Weinberg he's
Nobel Prize famous Nobel Prize winner
University in Houston in Texas and I
think it was Austin maybe Austin Texas
but the point is that steep and winding
burry I've got him here on on YouTube
and he says you know mathematics doesn't
explain mathematics only describes so at
least I've got two sources hopefully
there's some more out there but the
point is these people apparently are
seem to understand the difference that
you know an exploration is not a
description but see if you read the
article I wrote today you get people
like this other fellow from UCLA his
name is Lincoln I can't remember his
first name but whatever it is Lincoln
and he explains so he begins his video
that way saying he's gonna explain how
magnets work and you're gonna understand
today how magnets work and he goes
through all this seven or eight minutes
of video and then he and finally says
this is the bottom line he says well you
know the electron spin in the same
direction like both homes spin clockwise
great so what did you have you explained
all you did was describe you describe
that every time a magnet attracts
another you find that the electrons spin
in the same direction that's a
description you haven't explained how
the fact that like I say two basketballs
turn into that you come into a room you
find two basketballs that are turning in
the same direction they're approaching
each other why are they approaching each
other is there a wire
wound around their equator x' is their
air pushing them together what's the
cause what's the mechanism by saying
that they spin clockwise both of them
you're not explaining it you're just
describing and so the question is do all
these mathematicians understand what a
description is and and separate it from
what an explanation is and you got the
other case of another Nobel Prize mentor
Richard Fineman he claims to explain how
magnets attract each other also and he
does a big mess of it he takes eight
minutes to say he doesn't know and again
he goes into the same rigmarole he says
you know what depends on the level you
want to understand it at well I wouldn't
understand it at the baby level at the
kindergarten level please make it as
simple as possible well he says he can't
do that that you got to go to the
university to understand how magnet
attracts another why do you go because
you're stupid huh you do stupid yeah no
no because they want to introduce math
and I don't want math because math can
only describe according the Weinberg and
according to Donald Semin a so please
don't bring your math just tell me you
know what the trick is tell me how the
magician did the trick that's all I want
to know and they can't do that they
can't do that because in order to do
that you have to you have to make an
assumption about the invisible entities
that you know mediate and that's where
the problem is these people and some of
those people and I think even many of
the Nobel Prizes out there they don't
understand the difference between a
description and an explanation and so
whether they do or not is still up in
the air I'm not sure they do understand
that you know they they probably if you
push them against the ropes as they're
well description is an explanation well
I thought you said that science doesn't
explain that science described what did
you mean so it's up to them to tell us
to define the terms description and
explanation so that we can understand
whether they understood and I don't
think they they really got that yet they
don't have a definition for these
keywords they just use them and they
probably just referred to whatever's
ordinary dictionary I don't think they
understand so that's my answer to you
Martin I got a big Nobel Prize question
right whoa we got a Nobel Prize present
please go to religion philosophy er
let's assume and it's not a far-fetched
assumption that's assume we have a
mathematician right mathematical
physicist so we visit the asylum okay go
to the asylum okay and this guy just for
the sake of it I mean this is for all
you mathematic mathematical physicists
out there you could probably answer this
or not my dad but I guess the question
is could there be a more precise
mathematical equation that
mathematicians aren't using since
they're looking in the wrong place since
they're always looking in the same place
they could describe the rope model and
thereby all the phenomenon in the
universe or I guess better phrase is is
the equation for the grand unified
theory and all the equations that are
looking for hidden in the equations used
to describe a twine rope and I can
answer that question fortunately I can
and there's a couple answers to that
question the first one is we do have an
equation and it's C equals wavelength
times frequency it's it's been settled
you know we don't need to look for
something because this equation has been
around
it's a derivation from Maxwell's for
primary equations okay C equals C is a
constant C is the velocity of light you
know the velocity of light it's equal to
frequency times wavelength if you reduce
the frequency you know because they're
inversely proportional when you reduce
the frequency you have to increase the
wavelength and vice versa
okay so they're inversely proportional
because the speed of light has to remain
constant for whatever reason let's not
worry about right now the physical
reason it remains constant let's just
say one goes up the other one goes down
so we do have an equation for the rope
that's the first issue
what's the second issue the second issue
is that as far as I've been looking at
you know if you go through the internet
you get very you won't find and analysis
of torsion waves what you will find lots
and lots and lots is okay so let's go
what's the torsion wave okay let's go
through that you know when when
originally when Huygens and really even
before that Robert Hooke was the guy as
far as I know Robert hooks the guy who
introduced waves he did that in the
1650s okay he did that quite early few
years later we have Huygens who picks up
on this and he writes his a wave book
you know we're not talking about
torsional waves were talking about waves
we're talking about waves in general so
let's stop there we have because we'll
see how this progresses okay and
hooligans goes in and analyzes waste but
what does he analyze he analyzes
longitudinal waves that's what he
thought you know like was and that's how
he analyzed it in his book seminal book
known as the treatise on light that's
what his book was called okay and Newton
opposed that he says no no I don't agree
that light is uh comprised of waves
I think it's particles and so they came
with this particle and wave fight do we
need to know the laws yeah it's a like
you know when you see sound waves yeah
it moves in the direction in other words
back and forth right in the direction of
motion of travel and that's more or less
what you have also for to some degree
for water waves and that's what he was
visualizing he was kind of explaining it
in those terms then it wasn't until you
know the 19th century early 19th century
you have Kristin Fred friend now and
what he does is he says no look we've
been mistaken all these years really
it's a transverse wave and when he
stopped you there
right now we have launched it we have
with airwaves sound water waves which
are like going over the can intermediate
yeah and now we have transverse waves
waves and torching waves loading yeah
holy but transverse waves means that is
it yeah and it's a two-dimensional see
the longitudinal wave is considered a
one-dimensional way because it just
moves in a straight line just back and
forth along the same axis whereas now
you have the transverse wave which is
introduced by Augustine Fred Fred Nell
in France and he says look this thing is
an oscillation that goes up and down
perpendicular to the motion of the wave
that's what's called the transverse wave
because it's moving up and down like if
you take a rope and you shake it up and
down you'll see the the goosebumps right
back to the rope right now I feel you
did there okay so we have the goosebumps
and so those two waves the longitudinal
wave and the transverse wave have been
analysed to exhaustion and one of the
guys who did the transfer a transverse
wave to exhaustion is mr. Maxwell you
know James Maxwell worked on transfers
where he was convinced like was a couple
of transfers wave electric and magnetic
that ran perpendicular to each other so
he did a full analysis of that you don't
need to do any more because you got to
do is read Maxwell and you're done you
everything you wanted to know about
transfers way pretty much came out of
him and that's why he's a hero in the
mathematical world what no one has done
Maxwell Huygens any of those is look at
torsion ways and what is the torsion
wave torsion wave is you take a rope you
take it straight it's already straight
so you don't have to wave it up and down
you don't have to move it back and forth
none of that all you do is torque it
it's a torsion that moves along the way
yeah along the rope so you take your
grandmother's rope and you put too close
pins you touch one and if you try to
film it like I've tried to do that I've
they done this you can't see how fast
the other guy moves it moves
instantaneously there's a there's a
YouTube channel called smoke slow mo
guys who do a lot of things they just
keep doing things and they put it in
real slow-mo like throw a water balloon
against the wall really smoke and right
right right and I guess that would be
one for them where they take a
clothespin and go like say if you can if
you if you can film a trillion you know
frames for a second you turn one
clothespin and see how long it takes
until your eyes and and you know nothing
beats a torsion wave nothing
no car no airplane no rocket nothing in
this planet that you can imagine beats a
torsion wave and that pretty much tells
you something about the nature of light
because light is pretty fast it's Swift
it's three hundred thousand kilometers
per second that sounds fast and yeah it
is and so the question is here you have
a model for the swiftness of light first
second you have the links that verify
Maxwell's equations equals frequency
times wavelength wavelength becomes
shorter you have more links more
frequency frequency becomes lower you
have lower frequency you have longer
wavelengths same yeah you have it this
is what they're describing they've been
described you know you took this the
more you torque it the more links you
have and the shorter the link and vice
versa when you enter kit you know what
you have is fewer links and longer links
so so C equals F frequency times
wavelength is the equation of a rope
there's no other there's no other entity
that you can imagine that can simulate
that you can use to simulate that
equation that should give you you got
the speed you got the inverse relation
between frequency and wavelength it's
just like this is it
and these guys are still dealing with
transverse waves and saying well we left
the longitudinal wave in the past but
there's one more thing we should
understand about this and that's that
during earthquakes during earthquakes
right this has been measured this has
been already verified by the repetition
proven this is we have proof during
earthquakes longitudinal waves like air
that move back and forth move 1.7 times
faster than transverse waves up and down
so they measure these things the
geologists that analyze these thing they
said look we looked at the trend a they
have a way of measuring these things and
they say look that the longitudinal wave
moved faster than the transverse wave so
we get it a little bit expect yeah but
we get my point is we have it the world
in Reverse here you have the torsion
wave which is swift as like now instant
and that leaves the poor longitudinal
wave in the dust and the longitudinal
wave leaves the tracer wave in the dust
and they're saying light is a transverse
wave
that's the world we have today that
thanks to the mathematicians they have
it completely in Reverse I hadn't a
question and they don't have any
analysis of torsion if you look up there
you won't find too much information
under torsion that's my point that's
where the Nobel next Nobel is hidden in
torsion waves because if you get because
I'm sure there's more ways to describe a
torsion wave than the one you proposed
on that it was an inverse oh we have a
question from Thomas yeah is torsion on
a normal rope speed of sound speed of
light maybe ya know it's the speed now
remember remember the speed of the sound
is measured in what is it 400 meters
yeah yeah meters that kilometer the
meters per second it's like between 400
and 600 can't really be gone faster yeah
yeah Jets go faster than this
so no hopefully not because it is
perhaps late but could superimpose arose
be the cause of redshifted yeah oh [ __ ]
well let me tell you if you look at why
God doesn't exist it'll tell you what
what the redshift is due to okay and I
don't know if you've heard of this
fellow who was kicked out of the United
States what was his name died recently
like one or two years ago anyways he
fought that he said the redshift has
nothing to do with the receding galaxies
and to some degree I think he's right he
was saying the C feed very very stars
out there you know he's saying we're
confusing distance with shininess okay
but that's one at one argument the other
arguments the one I have and that's that
you know as a rope comes out of an atom
distant atom and as it approaches us it
does slowly
you know the links become longer and
longer and and that's your red ship
right there I think that's what you'd
expect right and and that's the red ship
that's the cause of the ratio if you
take a and you just turn one end of it
right until that the tightness of that
goes along it starts widening out and
that's the point that's where the
redshift comes in right so when a galaxy
approaches you it it pushes all the
links tends to push the links together
and that's a blue-shifted
that's why when it approaches you it's a
blue shifted galaxy for example
Andromeda is approaching the solar
system and because it Andromeda is
approaching us
Andromeda's blue shifted and that
violates the you know the Big Bang
Theory because Big Bang supposedly
everything's going outwards okay and and
conversely
anything that is receding from us would
tend to you know make the links longer
and that's why it's redshift
so it doesn't have to do with in other
words it does it does it does have to do
with whether a galaxy's approaching or
not where were general relativity fails
is in explaining why I'm dromeda
galaxies and all the ones in the in our
what is called the local group which is
about twenty galaxies why they are blue
shifted and so they have to put a little
you know fixed in there and they said
well you know the reason they're blue
shifted is that electromagnetism is
overcoming gravity that's the that's the
solution they have today they say look
the electromagnetic forces magnetism
specifically magnetic fields they're
overcoming gravity but it turns out you
know this this galaxy is in the middle
of nowhere
it's a millions of my Lily ins of
kilometers away millions of light-years
away and you're saying what the the
magnetic field of our galaxy is reaching
all the way up there and overcoming the
gravitational attraction or in this case
the opposite I guess yeah you can't
explain because what they're saying is
the Big Bang is pushing the galaxies
outwards because everything's exploding
right to hand-grenade or pulling but it
turns out that the electromagnetic field
of the of our galaxy is overcoming that
expansion and pulling on dromeda inwards
well if you want to believe that yeah
you might as well believe in witches
this question I really like this
question of red shifted galaxies with
the rope model because there's a thing
that we haven't talked about there and
not only to explain it now because we're
a Doppler shift no no but there's
there's friction in the rope because if
that signal essentially what we're
saying is the longer signal travels the
more torsion as' it leaves behind it
leaves its energy
so to speak the longer travels that is
its kind of leaving more and more motion
behind it so at some point it's barely
any motion going out but so there's this
weird hint or clue of how the ropes
behave yeah but remember in nature of
the length of signal yeah but keep in
mind that we have to explain why we can
see the Andromeda galaxy and we do see
it but we see it blue shifted so we have
to explain those both phenomena why it's
blue shifted and why we can see it and
you know what are we going to say we
have to explain it under the Rope model
I think there's no problem with
particles I don't know you tell me how
we're gonna explain it with particles
and that's homework for Sunday so we'll
see you then same time same station
we'll see you there
bye bye